to catar e aí a estrutura na altura não
sei mas é meu próprio eu pedi pra você
escolher uma fase nelson rodrigues a eu
fazer um vídeo que você escolher o
botafogo exibia a frase que ela escolheu
foi essa nadamos o vídeo mais do que a
coragem é alheia à vontade pra vocês vão
ver o que acontece muito comigo
brasileiro que não faz muita coisa agora
ele vê outra pessoa fazendo ele vai lá e
faz a pessoa de 1928 eu fico todo eu
fico com onde só porque porque a pessoa
tinha 19 professor vai sem coração ante
2,9 na redonda para 9 afi dois e depois
que eu vim para tirar 19 assim eu crio
coragem ao estudo a resposta e volátil
nota mais alta que é 4 mas não me
esforcei o que importa é que eu me
esforcei aí sim eu criei coragem o
brasileiro é assim nada mais no mundo dá
coragem a ele do que ele vê uma pessoa
fazendo uma coisa melhor que até no
futebol quer ver que ele não precise
fazer de coitada a gente vai lá e faz o
pessoal esse vídeo é uma homenagem aos
brasileiros foi trazido para vocês pela
claro a única com 4g mais rápido do
mundo que você gostou e quer ver mais
conteúdo legal comecei aqui é só clicar
aqui do lado na playlist nelson explica
e lógico se você gostou desse vídeo
daquele gostei eu quero que você comete
aqui em baixo o que é que lhe dá coragem
como é que embaixo eu quero levou a
escolher alguns comentários o que lhe dá
coragem vai poder assistir se viu até
aqui é nós